welcome to day two of the st. Louis
Invitational here at the chess club and
scholastic center of st. Louis I'm Ben
Simon we have finished up three rounds
in the tournament's to determine if
anyone will earn their GM or I am norms
respectively today every single game
except for one was a draw John
Bartholomew earned his first Grand
Master norm last fall right here at the
club he's trying to repeat here to get
his second but it's proving tough today
he drew with Andre Corbett's it was a
very interesting game he played the
gingy Indian pretty unbalanced line I
played it a couple times myself so I
kind of had an idea what to do against
it but it did catch me completely off
guard that Andre played that the gingy
Indian is kind of characterized by this
very unbalanced pawn structure that
arises and i played this move Queen a
four because when i played this in the
past I know that black wants to get
their queen to a five so this is like a
way of pre-empting that plan and he
reacted well I thought and the middle
game was very interesting we traded
queens now structurally like whites
worse so I should play to open the
position with my bishops so I wanted to
try and arrange the pawn break efore
which I was able to do but he played
this move b5 and I thought that was a
nice response because now when I capture
and he takes suddenly I have some
problems in the center and on the
queenside to think about so I had to
bring my bishop back to defend upon he
played his Bishop out this was really
like the climax of the middle game
because he played c4 here which at first
I thought I was in trouble his idea is
to try to surround my d5 pawn so
possibly even dropped his night back to
c7 without allowing me to play pawn to
c4 to defend it but I think I found a
decent way out so I took his pawn
establishing material equality again
he took then played night c7 and again
if I don't play actively here I could be
in trouble because my d5 pawn is a goner
so I brought my bishop back attacking e7
he defended now Bishop g5 so I'm kind of
relying on tactics and the ability to
open the position to compensate for the
pond that I'm probably going to lose on
d5 and he did take it I got rookie for
an attacking c4 and we got into an end
game where I thought I had some pressure
so Connie 7 but Andre defended very well
like here I was looking forward to
pressing with my two bishops versus two
nights and also he had about one minute
on his clock compared to maybe eight
minutes for me so I was trying to make
the most of my chances here but he shut
me down pretty effectively brought his
King up I took took here now he
eliminated my F for Bishop which was
smart of him and I think like maybe in
this end game I have a couple chances
but with my extra pawn but I kind of
rushed things this was pretty
instructive coming up right here he
pointed out after the game that I didn't
have to play to move f5 immediately that
was kind of premature because he gave
his King a nice in route via e 52 f 4 so
I think here if I would have improved my
position a little bit maybe played like
King g2 and bring it up to g3 and wait
and see and be in a better position to
push up five later I think I might have
had some chances but as it was I pushed
we traded and he was able to bring his
King up he offered a draw right here and
we were talking about and actually like
I probably have to be a little careful
at this point so it's kind of glad y'all
could draw because my bishop has no
targets and all those pieces are very
active so overall I think a draw was a
good result based on how the game went
is very unbalanced struggle last night
round to kind of shook up the rankings a
little bit here
round 3 everything is a hold every
single game was a draw in the GM section
even though yesterday arun sharma shone
brightly today he could not get past
LaVon Bergonzi bergonzi scored the only
decisive game this round we recently
played in Chicago about like two days
before this tournament started and he's
a really good player so I tried to
prepare some opening that I don't really
I don't usually play so I decided to
play banani I haven't analyzed this game
using the engine yet but the oldest most
were all this moves look natural age 6
because my idea was to play f5 here and
after night g5 night transfers to e6
which is pretty annoying for black so I
decided to play h6 first and then go f5
and here g4 I think this is not the best
move for white because you know it opens
up the king and at the same time weakens
the king so g4 didn't really stop by
five anyways so after a fine night g3
rook takes Knight takes Queen d 6 i'm at
this point i think like how it has a big
advantage because b5 is coming and i
have consolidated my paces and i have
two bishops advantage so um 22 b5 takes
take 61 ok fade g5 takes takes chief I
and we'll see a Bishop g2 and here I
just I just blundered and left the pawn
on c5 because i hallucinating i thought
after Queen c5 i was just winning after
Bishop h2 and i didn't see a simple move
King f1 which is which is pretty simple
to see so I dropped this point but my
position is so good it's it's still
better for black i think i have a
compensation so king of six tweenage
Simon rookie salmon check Bishop d6 rook
Queen a to g5
here i spend about like 10 to 15 minutes
and i couldn't find any like
continuation that could create real
threat for why did I decide to play King
Jade which is an earth I think he should
have taken F takes g 5 25 and probably
King f1 just stops blacks attack and i'm
down to pause I still have some
compensation obviously attack but i
don't think i have anything significant
here he did not capture the phone he
played who kept one after which g4 is
just extremely strong and I think legs
close to winning and Queen c3 is just a
blunder I took takes captured the pawn
and he blunder he captured the pawn
after which he loses the piece but even
if he doesn't capture and go maybe
Bishop f 3 i'll just play rookie three
anyways she's gonna move his night and
then i'll take the pawn and just simply
winning for black so he captured rookie
3 his sector Bishop for three pawns but
they should just hopeless because two
bishops are really strong checking g2
rugby three and now I'm through I'm
attacking the night and at the same time
on to play Bishop h3 so his was in the
Peace and he resigned here Iskander era
pop needs to win every single game from
here on out to stay in the running that
is highly improbable but it is still
possible these videos cover the ends of
every odd number round but remember you
can check out all of the games as they
happen there's two rounds a day 11 a.m.
and 6 p.m. central at st. Louis chess
club org